make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into
absolute carnage and and here's the
thing so the original absolute carnage
or against the first issue is split into
three parts and for the most part it
looks like it's what they're gonna do
from the issues going forward I have not
read the the physical issue number two
yet so I'm not sure I've been on
vacation for the last week driving the
Pacific Coast Highway which was amazing
but kind of getting into this one then
we'll actually do the third part of the
first issue later on this week so what
kind of what kind of wrap everything up
in the last one it was really like the
return of Cletus Kasady right and that
was a big thing that that was that was
people were really expecting and had
really been told to us in the events
leading up to absolute carnage it was
kind of the big the the big takeaway
from it right I mean Cletus Kasady is
the original carnage he's a fan favorite
has been for a long long time and as one
of those things were unless his Cletus
Kasady plain carnage people are kind of
you know kind of iffy about it the only
really exception to that is Norman
Osborn when he was the red goblin that
was really really cool actually talked
about him here in a little bit but what
this does is it picks up with Peter and
Eddie Brock and then of course you know
Eddie's Eddie's son Dylan all basically
getting yet getting together in Converse
and the reason why is because again when
it came to carnage first popping up of
course it was fears it was spider-man
and venom who fought him and then you
went into maximum carnage which was
spider-man and venom fighting him
fighting him again and and the idea is
that with someone like carnage it takes
the two of them to succeed because
carnage is so incredibly strong right
the fact that the symbiote is bonded to
the blood of Cletus Kasady is what
really amps up his powers beyond what
you normally see with like venom or
anybody along those lines anybody that
normally wears the symbian and so it
makes sense that you would see any kind
of team up with spider-man now for a
long time carnage fans and really long
time spider-man fans this kana has to be
a bit of a hit into the nostalgia feels
right it's kind of like man this is this
is kind of this kind of feels a little
bit old-school
and that's why it's kind of a cool
moment is because a lot of things have
transpired in the life of Eddie Brock
that Peter Parker didn't know about for
example Peter Parker does not know that
Dylan is the son of Eddie now of course
when Eddie sins doing away says hey look
go do something else just don't be here
it's adult talking time you guys all
remember that for when you were kids
it's a chance for Eddie to basically
sort of kind of let his guard down right
and just sort of let the whole thing
kind of be out there and say hey look
like he's my kid and this isn't really
even about me it really it's not even
really about me stopping carnage it's
about like stopping him to make sure
that my kids safe right because of
carnage gets his hands on my kid go kill
him and
really just protecting people outside of
myself and that's why it's a really
important thing right because Eddie's
been a bad guy he's been a good guy he's
been a victim of circumstance
spider-man seen a lot of things
transpire with the character of Eddie
and this is kind of the newest take for
his character insofar as he's out there
in coping with a few things and it works
and it is really cool to see because it
kind of makes spider-man a little softer
to him and say okay you know I guess I
can kind of get where you're coming from
but then suddenly they're met with a
news broadcast and there's this mass
grave that was essentially dug up out in
the middle of nowhere it initially is
kind of like whatever man nobody wants
to see as they turn it off Eddie Brock
starts freaking out spider-man's like
what the heck is going on and he was
like everybody who's ever been a symbian
is buried out there like they're there
in that mass grave right and that's one
of the big things that we recall from
what we've been told both during the pre
loot stories to do absolute carnage and
by the interviews that the Donnie Cates
has done himself that you have this
circumstance where Cletus Kasady is
basically going around and grabbing what
I call these code X's right these little
codices pieces and is designed to
basically like kind of recreate the
whole right it sort of been that way
ever since Knoll popped up in the sense
that like when Noah was there it was he
was the guy that crate all the symbiotes
they function as a cohesive unit and
following his defeat they've kind of
been separated ever since and as the
current symbiote basically grabbing all
these different iterations of either
itself or venom and them's combining
them all into a singular unit which will
amplify his power even further and then
presumably try to take on nolan and you
know destroy nolan to become like god of
the symbionts which makes sense to be
actually really cool to see if carnage
like took over all the symbiotes and
became their new god ah but it's a cool
little thing here because what you get
is this revelation you know where where
Eddie is freaking out he's kind of
panicking the big thing to really come
out of this is he saying like Annie's
body is buried out there somewhere now
for those of you guys who have not been
keeping up with Donny cases run on venom
and and really aren't longtime readers
of the spider-man comics and the person
he's referring to Annie she's actually a
character that appeared back in amazing
spider-man 375 in 1990 93 and this is
Annie Wayne now any weighing is actually
the second person to host the Venom
symbiote and in fact she used the name
she venom at one point in time but she's
also the biological mother of Dillon and
for those and the reason why I say
Donnie Cates Run is because in the early
part of his run when you basically got
the introduction of Dillon's character
it was amy was pregnant with Eddie
Brock's son she didn't want Eddie to
know because of course he was venom he
was a bad guy at the time and so she
basically gave birth to the kid dropped
it off at the father of Eddie Brock's
house and then just kind of left her
there and then eventually she went and
jumped off a bridge and died but the
idea behind it is that basically his
ex-wife is out there and that she can
basically be
used by carnage to become one of his
henchmen or what have you it's kind of a
crushing thing and that's reason why
Eddie sword starts to freak out now
again this is one of the cool things
about his character because if we're
talking about like 1990s venom lethal
protector you know and weird is sort of
like he's about doing his own thing of
being a bad guy he probably wouldn't
have cared about that but the nature of
Eddie is that over the years his
characters become a lot more dynamic has
become a lot more intrigue and he's
grown a lot in terms of what writers
have done with him and in kind of how he
views the world but it's a cool thing
because it's kind of like okay so like
the notion that Eddie Brock has a lot
more on the line than Carnage's back
let's fight him it's cool it's something
that I'm really really digging about the
way his characters being handled that's
why I love the venom run from from
Donnie Cates so much because it's almost
kind of seems to be more focused on
Eddie than it is on the symbiote itself
right I mean the Venom's to me it's
super popular that kind of makes sense
and so in response to this with
everything kind of pop it off the way
that it is there something burglars at
bust in and spider-man takes care of
them quick fast and in a hurry and it's
kinda like okay you know cool whatever
and then he's like we need to go see a
guy they could basically help us get
this stuff sorted out and of course
that's when they basically go back to
Rex Strickland safehouse of course rush
Strickland being one of the previous
hosts for the Grendel's Indians I'm kind
of the precursor to venom basically and
then of course they're essentially
talking with the maker now this is kind
of a cool moment because the idea of the
maker meeting spider-man is a cool
little thing right because in Marvel
they never actually met before like
they've never really met I mean even
with spider-man there during the events
of secret Wars like his dealings were
with like Miles Morales and with with
the molecule man Owen Reese and of
course you know Reed Richards from his
main universe but like that was
basically it
you know the maker kind of being out
there and and being part of the equation
and everything it's kind of a cool
little moment here because you know when
you have Eddie show up here one of the
things we end up learning is again the
mysterious benefactors the people that
that maker works for that we don't
really know who they are it's basically
like hey they had a lot of interest in
using the carnage symbiote or even the
venom Sumida itself they want to know
how to like use them for their own ends
either weaponizing them using them for
new technologies whatever the case
happens to be but like they've been
working on a means to extract the
symbiote from individuals already and
then do it in a way that's safe that can
preserve the life of the person who is
infected and so was kind of a cool
moment here because when this happens
you basically have like Spider Man
talking to him but then also bringing in
his godson Normie Osborn now Normie
Normie Osborn okay this characters
interesting um he almost kind of has the
Franklin Richards effect in the sense
that like he first popped up back in
like amazing spider-man 2 85 and then
like No
he really did anything with him after
that not for a long time Norman Osborn
really had his big moment during the red
goblins storyline and we never actually
covered that the go down swinging
storyline we never actually covered that
I feel like we should if for no other
reason than the fact that like it ties
in pretty neatly with absolute carnage
but basically Norman Osborn is the son
of Harry and the grandson of Norman so
Norman Osborn as most of you guys know
is the Green Goblin right in the big
moment he had over the course of the
entire publishing career was throwing
gwen stacy off the bridge and in certain
circles there's still a debate that goes
on over who actually killed Gwen Stacy
if it was the Green Goblin who killed
her before spider-man got there or if he
was spider-man shooting his webbing into
her foot and they're like her neck
snapped right because it goes both ways
there's actually there's an actual
onomatopoeia in the comic it says like
snap right like her neck snaps and then
in the same comic you know the Green
Goblin is like I killed her before you
got here so there's fans that kind of go
either way and really kind of the
argument rages still to this day ah but
following that really like the the next
big moment I would say in the history of
Green Goblin like the really huge
landmark kind of character shifting
moment came during the events of Dark
Reign right you come out of Secret
Invasion Tony Stark is kicked out as
director of shield after the fact that
neo Scrolls have been replacing humans
and various superheroes and Tony Stark
didn't know um and so he's replaced with
Norman Osborn who had a key piece of
information that turned the tide of the
secret invasion war that basically led
to humanity winning and so he dismantled
shield he basically creates hammer and
he goes forward doing villain things
because he's a bad guy and then tries to
like basically conquer the United States
than eventually the world now ultimately
he's defeated he's thrown in jail and
then along the way the Green Goblin kind
of bothers him a little bit kind of
harasses him and then ultimately he
recalls hammer makes his escape and then
he was kind of free-floating after that
and then you go into basically the red
goblin story which is kind of a kind of
an attempt to bring Norman Osborn back
but then modify it right so give him the
current symbian and basically become a
combination of the Green Goblin and and
the carnage symbiote which is basically
red goblin I mean it was a cool thing
but during that story
what he did is he's actually kidnapped
Normie and then basically you know put a
piece of the of the symbiote into Norman
Osborn and then turn him into what was
called goblin child and it was kind of a
cool little little segment it was a
crowd of those a cool low thing it
didn't really last long enough to see
where it went just because of the fact
that you were coming up on the end of a
dance lots run and that basically went
into the new era of spider-man with Nick
Spencer but it was a cool little thing
it was it was a cool moment and a cool
bit of storytelling but that really
Norman
were just kind of been in Ravencroft
ever since when he never since the
events of the red goblin story when he
was defeated he's has kind of been
locked up and in prison but that's why
Normie Osborn is here is because because
of the fact that he held the simian at
one point that codex is there now
remember the codex is really dotty
Kate's way of explaining how it is that
the Venom symbiote could leave Peter
Parker and then go to Eddie Brock and
still remember everything about Peter
Parker right it plants a little piece of
itself a little memory a little little
tiny knowledge fragment a little nugget
of information in Peter leaves it there
and it always happens from one host to
the next as was basically carnage going
around and trying to take each one of
those individuals into himself and
capture their codex by default and so
initially the idea of the maker is well
if this kids been exposed to the codex
then let's basically take a blood sample
and see if we can't find a way to you
know find a weakness or or you know what
this codex means and if we can use
information there to take out carnage of
course the response to spider-man is
absolutely not I'm not gonna let some
crazy guy who is an alternate reality
version of Reed Richards take a blood
sample off of my godson because I don't
know what this guy's gonna do with it if
he's gonna create like a thousand clones
of this kid kudos like this guy's kind
of bonkers and in reality he's right the
maker is kind of crazy but as a result
of this the makers like well then fine
give me somebody else give me anybody
else out there that you know of off the
top of your head right now who's held
the venom or the carnage symbiote and
then bring them here and there's only
one person that these two guys are aware
of there's only one individual that
these two guys know that they could
basically find locate bring them back
and then use that person as it means to
achieve this goal and we'll find out in
the next video with that being said guys
are gonna bring this to an end if you
guys are new here to comics explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb cork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]